[Musik]
die leute
hallo herr zukunft eine
die gespanne sitzung titel wir sind auf
einer kreuzfahrt wir sind ein land
wurden von der msc benehmt euch mit und
will den nächsten tag ich hier an bord
und wenn es jetzt auf jeden fall zeigt
was die polizei betont huber
okay heute läuft irgend ein wichtiges
fußballspiel am sa ist in ordnung kann
fußball gucken
oder die männer sind beim fußballgucken
ich habe nämlich auch eine richtig tolle
begleitung
meine freundin die sind auch mit
antworten semantik hätte vielleicht
schon instagram genau den junggesellen
abschiede dem taktischen bereich haben
soll den weg gerade
ist
schaut euch mal diese swarovski treffer
an jede stufe soll einen wert von 4000
euro haben
jetzt mache ich euch mal eine kleine
room to mich interessiert das nehme ich
auch immer wie die kabine aussieht und
zwar kommt ihr rein dann ist hier links
das bad dann hat man hier einen ring
diesem spiegel
hier ist das große bett und der
kleiderschrank man hier durchgeht hat
man hier noch einen schrank hier ist
auch noch mal ein spiegel
hier ist ein sofa hier guckt man dann
raus hafen balkon und das hier ist srey
und die ist so gut er immer irgendeine
frage
okay so wie ist das wetter heute kann
ich den kabinen fernseher jetzt
einschalten mega praktisch also ich
feiere das richtig richtig smart super
super smart wir sind gerade losgefahren
nicht komisch ab und werden hier noch
smoothies gestört in der runde
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
vor gästen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
wir haben gerade ein vier-gänge-menü und
gönnt sich einfach noch mal eine pizza
[Musik]
ja du schon oder
das halt in den pool das ist er komplett
überdacht genau richtig kuschelig
angriff
ich habe
eine haarlocke
jetzt ist der punkt damit gemacht
[Musik]
ja
zwei monden zur erde augen auf
ok
dies sei aber auch an dem ihr werdet
selbst gestorben wäre gestorben
nach zwei uhr morgens und ich gehe erst
mal kennen ja wir gehen jetzt erst mal
schlafen und morgen früh morgen ohne
wecker aufstehen vor luxus bestehen
morgen ohne wecker aufgerichtet und dann
ja wenn wir uns morgen früh
das mache ich morgen so guten lagen
leute er ist so krass gewesen ich bin
heute morgen aufgestanden haben sie war
ich drei minuten vor gebracht denn es
entsteht zum fenster hat die gardinen
erstmal aufgeschoben und ihr zeige ich
euch den blick den ich heute morgen
gesehen es ist so krass ich hoffe es
kommt in der kamera auch so rüber war
das wirkt so unreal das wirkt so als
würde ich auf dem riesen weiß ich nicht
nur riesen kinoleinwand gucken und sehe
dann diese ganzen welt aber das ist
einfach echt also bewegen uns ja einfach
mitten auf dem meer einfach nur krass
darauf jetzt ein latte macchiato
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ja
und jetzt haben wir uns zwar eine
massage beruft das auch richtig gefreut
bei mir ist es exakt ein jahr her
[Musik]
nach einer jetzt erst mal eine runde
laufen wird dann richtig klein aussehen
im seeland entspannter gemachten sie
ehrlich zugeben da er sich ein bisschen
aus der übung haben sich bei dir hause
können wir sehen hier ist ja eigentlich
ganz gut aus dass das ist die konkurrenz
wie viel von der stelle
die braucht er braucht von video
wer richtig sport
so das war also die massage war richtig
entspannend und danach sport hat auch
gut sport und eigentlich immer gut
sollte man viel öfter mal zeit für sich
nehmen
ich gehe zwar bei uns in bochum auch ab
und zwar um den block joggen das war's
dann aber auch schon geduscht habe mich
umgezogen und jetzt geht es wieder raus
zu messen
[Gelächter]
der presse
[Musik]
angemessen
kontakt besteht was ist so haben
wir stecken
[Musik]
ok
white chocolate
was schwierig man kann sich gar nicht
entscheiden sein
vorträge über die kamera ist mir doch
[Musik]
die pläne
vor das sieht gut aus jetzt gebe einen
tag
einen london das heißt wir verbringen
nächsten tag im wandern
nicht
hier gibt's übrigens hauseigenen
mozzarella also der wird hier ganz
frisch gemacht hier kann man richtig
rein schauen die maschinen und habe auch
schon probiert mega nehme ich mir
hier ist mit gemüse und die hier ist mit
aktivkohle im teig deshalb ist der teig
auf das schweizer einen italiener
natürlich immer erst die soße dann der
käse und dann der belag
denken wir mal
[Musik]
london
damit sei wieder das schon beim
nachtisch so gut aus
was für opfer
[Musik]
dafür schießen ist ohne waffe sie sind
profis ihn abschießen
ja
wir schießen rechten pfosten vorbei
das wird das heißt fünf felder zurück
wieder ist ein richtiges gezeigt und sie
haben wir haben versagt und morgen gehen
wir nach london und dann gute nacht und
bis morgen 8 juden 8 kanal sehen uns
morgen guten morgen wir sind in hat mir
ein seetag das heißt immer wenn man
gerade aus der kabine einmal ausgeguckt
hat hat man altes mehr gesehen was auch
richtig geil war und jetzt ich glaube
jeder passagier morgens nachdem nach dem
aufwachen läuft erstmal läuft erstmal
zum fenster und schaut was er heute
sieht und heute habe ich das gesehen
also das war heute mein ausblick
natürlich ikea direkt ins auge gestochen
und es ist aber auch ein schönes land zu
sein wir wollten sondern auf eigene
faust erkunden und
hansa dynamo und ich mache dann london
unsicher und nehmen euch mit arbeit geht
erst mal schnell was ist okay die sina
und der amicom da und ich hoffe jetzt
schon mal eine etage höher
frühstücksbuffet
da kommt da ganz bestimmt wenn es ums
essen gehen sie dann einen karamellsoße
sind schnecken belgische waffeln
pancakes oh mein gott 19 und zum
ausgleich gibt es natürlich darum
früchte also es ist nicht so dass wir
nur süßes essen 17 aus welcher früchte
gibt joghurt und stimmigen morgens gern
weil das eben lange satt
[Musik]
begehren von bord
komfort verkaufen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
geschafft
[Musik]
jetzt sind wir am piccadilly circus
bekannt für die großen leinwände und
würden gerne jetzt nach chinatown
angucken
nun sollen die leute auf das ruder
obwohl der abend einzig ist er kein im
programm ist also eine deflation oder
duisburg auf
[Musik]
da wollen wir jetzt rein da steht
nämlich irgendwas wird und das hat uns
richtig angelockt die donuts wie sich
all das müsste man im vergleich sehen
dass das ist kann man gar nicht sehen
diese immer so groß sie normal und ohne
gewähr
[Musik]
so wie in chinatown die sogenannte kopf
gefunden die stinkt wenn man sie auf
schneidet also sie soll nach so blöd es
auch klingen nach kopf zu stinken
hier ist eine die offene
bis 17
kann ich bestätigen ist echt nicht gut
das ist richtig gut
nein
[Gelächter]
jetzt sind wir wieder zurück sind
richtig müde war schon also anstrengen
in london hat richtig bock ist viel
gelaufen
richtig müde wie sein gute nacht wurde
wir sehen uns morgen wieder wieso wir
glaubt eigentlich ist gucken 52 18.000
8000 mindestens 18.000 schritte
mindestens also guten morgen diesem tag
beginne ich mal mit der aussicht von
ganz oben und ich habe ja auch einen
wundervollen blick über south hampton
also links ist alles land und rechts
seht ihr das meer ist die sky lounge
sind überwiegend erwachsene ruhe vor
kinder sagt haben soll
apropos druck hin da wenn ihr noch ein
kleines kind in euch hat sowie haben
soll ich dann geht ihr einfach dringt
die nur von der sky lounge oder er
wirklich kinder
ich zeige euch dreht sich jetzt einfach
mal um nachts häufig wirken und ja ich
feiere das selbst total
aber wir sind auch so spiele verrückt
eigentlich hätte nur zusammen was
außerdem müssen hansa diskutiert
wir sind wir beim babyklappe alle kinder
unter drei jahren haben wir sachen zum
spielen sind sich auch halten
miniclub sieben bis elf jahren zwölf bis
14 jahre da gibt's dann auch mal ein
fernseher tränen
genau wie sehen die kinder natürlich
nicht auf der webpage
wir werden youtuber gemacht haben hier
hätten wir unsere kennen die challenge
machen können wir haben uns ja
süßigkeiten kaum mit dem riesen
sitzkissen also nicht wundern dass ich
hier vor bepackt bin ist es total
angenehm warm hier
ich wollte gerne noch mal raus und ich
habe nicht viele fragen erreicht ob das
denn kindgerecht ist weil ich kann das
verstehen
ich habe ja auch viele manisa auf meiner
seite um die frage ist kindgerecht oder
echte verwachsen
wir sehen hier also für beide wirklich
[Musik]
lätta park vorliebe klettern lange nicht
mehr gemacht
[Musik]
und jetzt geht's ins special
mich lässt
so dass sie ist die galeria die habe ich
euch schon gezeigt aber ich bin immer
wieder fasziniert dass ich hier haben
wir zb ein projekte msc da könnt ihr zum
beispiel kuscheltiere kaufen und das
geht wenn man eine foundation dass es
fehlt komplett gespendet das finde ich
echt toll ich in den benjamin und
erklärt uns ein bisschen über die
foundation
[Musik]
da geht doch
dipl
[Musik]
hier seht ihr mann liebt das wirklich
meine allerliebste ecke auf dem schiff
das ist die patisserie von jean philippe
morin und das ist so toll hier dürfte
hier schon ganzen tag verbringen und wir
gehen jetzt auch mal rein
und dann stellen wir uns manchen kaffee
und vielleicht auch noch einmal gewonnen
[Musik]
besten klappt der kälte
[Gelächter]
hallo hamza klicken sie auf das kann man
hier steht sogar eine tisch normales
oder kann man gar nicht
durcheinanderkommen wie sonst was ist
wir sind ja hier die online shopper spa
da waren wir auch drin ist war auch
richtig lecker die ist da vorne direkt
also hier ne galerien ungelogen ich sage
es nicht nur so dass beste heißt dass
ich meinem leben je gegessen habe gehört
auch zuschauer filippo ja so hammer
[Musik]
ich noch vor dem videoclip hier ist das
atelier des true blood ihr bistro wird
auch live musik gespielt da vorne also
es ist echt echten highlight also ist
nicht nur einfach sitzen und gut essen
sondern entertainment einfach selbst
würde ich mal sagen die mir aufs zimmer
hatte man 70 gehen aufs zimmer ziehen
uns oben gucken und dann gehen wir essen
okay und ich schon wir gehen richtig
lecker essen
[Musik]
und wieder klassische theorie vermutlich
dann natürlich keinen darum mitschnitt
zeigen aber so ein paar einfache zeigen
trotzdem mitmachen
[Musik]
jetzt heißt es abschied nehmen wie
schade dass hier vor den fahrstühlen und
verlassen das aber echt schön muss es
richtig dick eingepackt also ich
zumindest vor dem frost draußen richtig
kalt wir hoffen dass euch der block
gefallen hat das war echt hart ich
dachte ja noch nicht rütteln blog
gemacht da können wir weitermachen
irgendwo auf reisen sind also wie gesagt
wir hoffen dass hat euch gefallen beim
nächsten blog sind wir dann
wahrscheinlich wieder bei mir in der
küche und das sind gerne in den
kommentaren austausch dir meine küche
vermissten sich sagen
also macht man in die band